The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osu.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi, everyone.
We're going to get started.
So today, we're--
it's another lab day.
So we're going to
split up, and half
is going to be outside again.
So hopefully, you
brought your coats.
If you haven't, you
should start learning
that's a good thing to do.
And then the other half
in the shop, finishing up
the woodwork you did.
And then we're also just going
to do some metal work and PVC
work just so you get familiar
with all the tools in the shop.
For the pumps, I
think [INAUDIBLE]
is going to talk a little bit.
I just wanted to mention.
Someone asked, like,
is a foot pump always
better than a hand pump?
And the answer is no.
There's a variety of reasons
why you might want a hand
pump over a foot pump.
One of them that's
a little subtle
is that in some cultures,
it's not acceptable for women
to stand over water sources.
And so you can't use a
foot pump as a woman.
And so if the woman needs
to be able to do the work,
she has to use a hand pump.
So there's many places
where foot pumps have not
worked because of that
reason, and hand pumps have
worked out great.
So there's-- I mean, I think
we'll talk about some other
reasons, but there's a lot of
variety in what's going to work
better, where, and why.
So yeah, it's not--
while you guys were
calculating power
and that's what we're
a little obsessed
about in this class, that's
not the only thing you
have to worry about
is maximum power.
PROFESSOR: OK, so addressing
the rest of the pump questions,
when you're actually trying
to decide what kind of pump
to implement in a
specific site, there
are a few things you need
to take into consideration.
First, you need to
figure out how much water
is going to be used.
If you're going to pump
bucket of water a day,
building an expensive rocket
pump doesn't really make sense,
and a hand pump
will do the trick.
Whereas if you're trying to
irrigate your entire field,
then maybe a cement pump is a
better alternative to the hand
pump because you
don't want to sit
there pumping with your hand
for hours and hours and hours.
That being said, the other
thing is that different pumps
can pump different
amounts of water
and can pump over
different pressure heads.
So the cement pump
is a diaphragm pump,
and I think it can pump about
5 to 7 meters deep only.
So it's not really used to
pump water from a low water
source like a borehole
or something like that
because it just won't
be able to do that.
A little bit about how it
works is you have two valves.
And then you have this sort of--
it's called a diaphragm.
And then you have
another valve here.
And so what happens
is this thing
can change anywhere between
this side and this side
when you step on it.
And so when you
step down, you're
constricting the volume here.
And water is going to
get pushed out of here
into this from your outlet.
And then when you release it and
you push up, this valve closes.
And then there's a
pressure difference in here
or negative pressure in here,
which will open this valve
and pull water in.
So it works pretty much the same
way with two one way valves.
But the thing is that
you can't generate
that big a pressure difference.
And that's why you
can't pump over that,
or you can't pump that deep.
And so that's another
one of the considerations
you have to take into account.
I think when you want to pump
from boreholes or something,
you want to get somewhere
around 50-ish meters deep.
I know the hand pump that
we went over the other day
pumps somewhere between
20 and 40 meters deep,
and the treadle pump, which you
may have seen in other places,
it's similar.
But instead of rocking
back and forth,
you lift up your legs up
and down kind of like this.
And it's the one that
IDE uses, and it's mostly
used for irrigation of fields.
And that one, I know, pumps
only seven meters deep.
And I lost my--
cool.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Have any
of these pumps been
used for, like,
filtrations and [INAUDIBLE]
for just carrying
[INAUDIBLE] water?
Can you put a filter--
it seems really rudimentary,
but can you put a filter
at the end of one of them, kind
of like a valve, and then just
collect [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I've seen people
use pumps with filters on them,
generally larger pore filters.
But the problem with
that is you normally
have to replace the
filter every so often,
and you don't want an
internal part of the pump
because it gets tedious to
replace it all the time.
But I've seen people put, like,
just cloth filters over the end
to get rid of turbidity.
PROFESSOR: Great, so because
a pump is pushing out
a relatively high pressure and
filters tend to work slowly,
it's rare that you can just
put a filter at the end.
So typically, while it
would be great to just
have point of use
water purification
and cleaning, apart
from turbidity factors,
it's hard to do
that effectively.
PROFESSOR: So,
yeah, so those are,
I think, the two biggest
questions from last week's lab.
Do any of you have
more questions
about last week's lab?
Cool.
So a little bit about what
we're going to do today--
the objectives are
we're going to try
to learn about how to get energy
from solar panels, PV panels.
So they're going to
be working with them.
We have one that's the size and
one that's maybe three times
the size of this.
So we're going to take these
outside and hook them up.
And then we're going
to learn about little
bit about the theory
behind not actually
how the PV panel works.
We'll go into that later.
But this is more
about how to use
the PV panel and some
applications that
come from that.
We're going to learn how
to hook it up to a battery
because that's one of the
most common uses, I think.
And we're going to look
at some of the design
considerations
you're going to have
to take into account
when you look
at designing a solar system.
And so that's sort of
one half of the lab,
and the other half is going to
be working in the shop again.
And you're going to learn more
about fabrication techniques.
But this time, instead
of working with wood,
we're going to look at other
materials like metal and PVC
and sheet metal.
Cool.
So where's my sheet?
OK, so when you're trying
to get energy, when you're
trying to get
power from the sun,
you basically have
your sun, and then you
have the surface of the
Earth and rays coming in.
Do any of you know how much best
case, when the sun is shining,
there's no clouds blocking
the way, what the best case
power you can get from the sun
is in watts per meter squared?
AUDIENCE: 1,000.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it's about 1,000.
Now at the beginning of
the first class we sat in,
we tried calculating the average
daily electrical consumption
or average electrical
consumption per year
for people living in
the developing world.
And based off of
those numbers, we
can approximate that
people in Nicaragua
use about 1 kilowatt
hours a day,
and then people living in Haiti
use about 0.1 kilowatt hours
of electricity a day.
So if we're looking
at solar, we're
looking to power all of these or
the one kilowatt hour, the 0.01
kilowatt hours, that people
are using in the developing
world using this energy.
How much surface area would
we need to harness the power?
So we can walk
through it, right?
And we get-- and then you
know that a day has 24 hours.
So you can multiply that out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 24 hours.
AUDIENCE: The sun doesn't
shine for 24 hours, though.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's true.
I will get to that in a second.
So you get about that much
surface area where you need.
So if you could ideally
harness the power of the sun
at this much power for 24
hours a day for one day,
you would only need
a collector that's
0.04 meters squared,
which is pretty tiny,
which seems like a
really good idea.
But there are a
lot of reasons why
this is not the right
way of figuring out
how much power you need.
So like said, for
example, the sun does--
how far down can you
guys read it again?
Is it about here?
AUDIENCE: A little lower.
There
PROFESSOR: There, OK.
So yeah.
So let's brainstorm
some of these ideas
or some of these reasons.
AUDIENCE: The maximum we know
is 1,000 watts [INAUDIBLE]
equals the sun
times [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Some people are going
to want more than one kilowatt
hour [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So to
find demand, it's
not always a exact same
match, so there's no storage.
It was-- because right now,
there's no storage yet.
So you might need fluctuations
from 0 to 1 for [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: You get, like, max,
about 30% from [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: That efficiency goes
down even more as the panels
age and also if it gets any
scratches or dirt on them.
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's start
looking at some of these
and quantifying some of these
constraints we have now.
So we can't do this anymore.
Let's still work with
these numbers as ballparks
because, I mean, we're
only really concerned
about the order of magnitude
estimations, really, for this.
So efficiency of PV--
and max, you get about 30%.
But I think that's
the laboratory cutting
[INAUDIBLE] technology
that is really expensive.
With commercially available
PV, it's somewhere
between 8% and 18% is what
you're going to get right now.
Yeah, we're not going
to look at that one yet.
So this one-- about
how many hours
do you think should
we approximate the sun
to be up a day?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: 10 hours.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
let's go 10 hours.
I think that's still a bit high.
I think somewhere
around 8 is better.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
assuming equatorial.
PROFESSOR: Let's go eight hours.
And then storage is
also a big factor
that you have a huge amount of
energy lost in storage as well.
This is one of the
reasons why just energy
is a problem because we have no
really good way of storing it
yet.
So generally, when
you are trying
to get power from
your solar panel,
you're going to try
to charge something
with it, like a battery.
And when you charge
a battery with it,
you have built-in losses.
And the efficiency
of transferring power
from a solar panel to
a battery without using
any voltage regulation or
anything because that has
energy loss too is about 75%.
And so now that you've
stored your energy,
what sort of
applications are you
going to try to power
off of this battery?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Like small appliances.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and
what kind of power
do small appliances take?
Are you going to--
AC?
So you're going to
have to convert this
because when you have
power stored in a battery,
it's stored as DC.
So you have to convert
it to AC again.
So you have this DC to
AC conversion, which
also has a loss in efficiency.
And then we can say
that's about 75% too.
It varies a lot depending on
how expensive your inverter is
and how you're matching your
loads with that inverter.
So it goes anywhere between,
like, 50% and 90%, I'd say.
But sticking to
75% is reasonable.
So now that we have
all of these numbers,
we can reevaluate
our calculations.
So we have one kilowatt
hours still for Nicaragua.
And now we're dividing
it by times 0.75.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Do-- I think we
want them in the denominator.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, let's
do this because I'm
running out of space.
And let's just say
that that's 10%.
AUDIENCE: 1 over the lifetime
of the [INAUDIBLE] efficiency.
PROFESSOR: Sure.
OK, and does someone have a
calculator and want to do this?
I can do it on my computer too.
Let's race.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Go, Jess.
Go.
AUDIENCE: 0.002777778.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I think that's--
well, it's kilowatts
divided by that.
So it's actually going
to be 2.7 or whatever.
It's going to be about
three meters squared.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, 2.7.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, which
is suddenly a lot larger
than what we had before.
And this is still
assuming that this is
going to be best case scenario.
And so if we assume
that the sun is
going to be shining
bright every day,
we're going to have to have
a solar panel at least three
meters or three square meters.
And then we have to think
about other things too
when we're dealing
with PV usage,
like what is the
power being used for
and how reliable
does it need to be.
So what are some
places where we could
think about installing
solar panels where
it wouldn't need to
be reliable and it
would need to be very reliable?
AUDIENCE: Hospitals.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I guess in a non-reliable, maybe
a home where you don't-- if you
have a house that's not using
refrigeration and they're using
lighting, if they don't
have electricity for one day
or something like that, it's
not the end of the world.
But when you're
looking at designing
a solar photovoltaic system
for a community partner,
you need to be asking
these sorts of questions.
Like, how long can
you go without power?
For a hospital, if you can't
go a day without power,
what do you do if there's no
sun for a week if it's cloudy?
You can't have
people who are on--
you just can't have
that for the hospital.
So you need to build a
more robust system that
can draw more power and store
it better whereas for housing,
maybe a couple of days if not--
where maybe you can afford
to go without electricity
for a couple of days.
So yeah.
And then does anyone know
what the cost of photovoltaics
is as well?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I
think the best things are
around $1 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, when
we were looking this up,
we found a pretty big range
for how expensive they were.
I think some most
of the sources were
saying it was around $3
to $5 for the cheapest
PV we could find, but it's
still about that order for watt.
And so I guess the thing you
should take away from this
is a lot of times, people look
at lighting and just say--
or electricity and
just assume that solar
is like a miraculous
solution that's
going to solve
everything, and you really
don't want to think
about it as that.
You want to actually
think about all
of the considerations that
go into creating a system.
So now I'll show you--
this is a solar panel
that we got for D lab.
We have two of these.
Basically, you have a positive
and ground coming out of it.
So you can hook it up to a load.
But if you want to hook
it up to a battery,
you have to somehow
regulate the voltage
before you're doing that because
if you plug this in directly
to-- well, what'll happen if
you're trying to charge a 12
volt battery and the solar panel
is outputting about 20 volts.
And it's a lead acid
battery, like a car battery
that you're trying to charge.
You'll probably-- yeah,
it'll probably explode.
I think if you drive
too much voltage
or shoot through a
car battery, you're
going to end up
producing hydrogen
and oxygen as byproducts,
and it's very flammable.
And if there's a spark,
then it explodes.
What about the opposite case
where your solar panel is
outputting eight volts
or something like that
or six volts, and your battery
is trying to take 12 volts?
AUDIENCE: It'll never
charge more than that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
more so than that,
though, not that it's
not only going to charge,
but your solar panel is going
to discharge your battery.
So you're going to
do the opposite.
So you need to build in some
sort of regulation for it.
You're going to have to have
a voltage regulator that
makes sure that you're
outputting the right amount
of voltage or--
and then you also
need to make sure
that you have a diode
in there somewhere so
that electricity doesn't back
flow and drain the battery.
Luckily for us, instead of
having to design and build
all of these things, there are
companies that do it for us.
So we have a couple of
these solar controllers.
And so they have
this stuff built
in so you can hook
a solar panel up
to two ends of this and your
battery up to the other two.
And then you can charge
a battery from that.
And this is just-- there
are two different ones.
This one takes-- this one
you can put a load directly
onto as well.
And the last thing I
was going to talk about
are resistors and
potentiometers.
Do you guys know how-- have
guys seen potentiometers before?
OK, yeah.
So what a potentiometer is,
it's a variable resistor.
And so this thing
is a resistant--
the thing has uniform
resistance that changes linearly
with how you turn this.
So if you're over
here, you effectively
have a resistor
that's this long.
And then when you
open it to this far,
you get a resistor
that's twice as long.
And so you can change the
resistance anywhere from 0 to--
this one's rated at 500 ohms.
And it's kind of
like what we did
the other day with
the resistance
is equal to rho l over a.
So you're just changing l
and getting more resistance.
So the way you use these,
you're going to use them
later on in the lab.
So I just thought I'd
explain it right now--
is you hook up to
these two terminals.
If you hook up across
here, you're just
going to get the full 500 ohms.
And if you hook up to here,
as you sweep this across it,
your resistance will go up.
And when your guys are
doing the lab, remember.
I wrote it as a note, and
I'll explain it again, there.
But remember that
when you're measuring
the resistance of this,
you want to disconnect it
from the solar panel
because if you don't, you're
going to fry the volt meter.
And it's not-- yeah, we don't
want you to fry volt meters
because they're expensive and
we only have two right now.
So do you have any
questions about what
we talked about right now?
OK, so we could split
into two groups.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
So everyone can sit down.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]